[Musique]
et maintenant retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de papy
grenier mais tu sais ce que je vais leur
faire à ce petit con moi oh les enfants
j'étais justement en train de parler à
votre mère tu nous racontes une histoire
ah une histoire est-ce que je vous ai
raconté la fois où j'ai vu une voiture
jaune ouais il s'est rien passé cette
semaine al putô est-ce que je vous ai
raconé la fois où j'ai survécu à
l'apocalypse c'était en 2008 et puis
n'avait pas installé une dictature
encore à
l'époque j'ai rien dit moi j'adore le
leader suprême pewdiep c'est une longue
histoire mais je vais commencer par le
début ah je me rappelle quand je suis
sorti du vagin quoi vous la voulez votre
histoire oui ou merde bon je venais de
naître et je m'appelais petite merde
c'est un joli non tu ne trouves pas il
voulait une fille à ma naissance papa a
voulu savoir la tête que à 20 ans euh
j'ai jamais compris le but de cette
machine en fait oh [ __ ] il est
dégueulasse habitant de l'AB si vous
regardez cette vidéo c'est que vous avez
été sélectionné pour assurer la survie
de la planète vous êtes la crème de la
crème du grand gâteau de l'humanité vous
êtes probablement
riche félicitations habitant de
l'abri depuis le grand boom le monde
extérieur n'est que pauvreté et
décadence regardez ces monstres il vous
tueraiit s'il le pouvait ça fait peur
heureusement nous sommes bien dans notre
abri je sais que tu as envie d'explorer
et de voyager mais ne t'inquiète pas le
jour viendra où tu pourras sortir et
montrer au reste du monde à quel point
tu es riche la vie dans l'abri c'était
un peu ennuyeux heureusement des fois il
y avait des événements je me souviens de
ma première fête d'anniversaire quand
j'ai eu 10 ans c'était la TEF
nous te souhaitons un joyeux
anniversaire je vais beau courir sur les
tables en utilisant mes pouvoirs
télékinésiques personne ne s'intéressait
à moi regardez-moi regardez-moi oh
j'étais un enfant turbulent ah là là
papa m'avait fait une surprise comme
j'avais 10 ans j'étais assez grand pour
manier ma première arme à feu ta propre
arme à air comprimé quoi les armes ça
m'a jamais empêché de devenir un AD
mature et responsable c'est prai
qu'est-ce que tu as dit je te buté c'est
c'est lequel il m'avait donné une
carabine à plomb pour tirer sur des
cafards et à la place j'ai tiré toutes
mes munitions à l'arrière de son crâne
ah j'étais un enfant turbulent
d'ailleurs je me souviens qu'à cet
anniversaire un des garçons qui
s'appelait BCH a déclenché une BAGAR
pour me piquer un gâteau ouais c'est ça
merci loser oh et joyeux anniversaire et
qu'est-ce que tu as fait papi non rien
du tout par contre quand j'ai eu 19 ans
j'ai laissé sa mère mourir dans un
incendie après je l'ai tué j'ai arraché
sa tête j'ai tabassé sa tête avec une
batte de baseball et puis j'ai utilisé
sa tête pour faire des bisous au cadavre
de sa mère
euh regardez-moi je suis Butch je mange
des
gâteaux euh personne ne pique mon
gâteau bref un matin j'ai appris que mon
père s'était évadé de l'abri pour aller
aider des gens à l'extérieur bon j'avais
pas trop compris pourquoi mais ce que je
savais c'est que c'était le moment de
sortir le monde avait besoin de moi
j'étais le héros j'étais riche et
j'avais un pe boy c'était vachement
pratique on me l'avait offert quand
j'avais 10 ans par exemple si je
marchais sur une mine pour savoir où
j'étais blessé il suffisait juste de
regarder mon PeiP Boy
et ah je n'ai plus de jambes
ah en plus de ça je pouvais regarder la
carte regarder dans mon sac à dos
invisible recevoir une des nombreuses
radios salutations ma très chère am et
même arrêter le temps s'il vous plaît
par ici venez s'il vous
plaît marginax il essaiera de prendre
votre argent sa vie a moins de valeur
que la vôtre il n'est pas riche son
évolution est cl je pensre la seule s ah
c'était super pratique c'est dommage que
ça avait que 30 minutes d'autonomie
comme une game on dit UNE gamear papi oh
excuse-moi je suis vieux à l'extérieur
de l'abri j'avais choisi une approche
furtive dans ce monde où les dangers
sont omniprésents je me disaient qu'il
valait mieux rester discret et puis
aussi parce que les gens était vraiment
très con la
démocratie c'est bon il n'y a rien ici
ah j'adore cette musique ma théorie
c'était que les radiation avait
durablement affecté ce qui était resté à
l'extérieur des
abris des millions de gens sont infectés
par des troubles visuels qui sont les
premiers sign av en coureur d'un AVC
alors faites-vous dépister à moins que
ça soit juste que vous êtes un peu con
quoi qui a dit ça et puis bon finalement
la discrétion c'était pas que la
furtivité ça me permettait aussi d'être
le meilleur des pic pocket oh après à
cette époque les gens avaient des
réactions un peu bizarres tu pouvais les
fouiller autant que tu voulais tant que
tu prenais rien ça all les gens disaient
rien ils étaient sympas quand même parce
que bon moi perso ça m'emmerderait mais
par contre si par erreur tu prenais un
truc qui t'appartienait pas au B
rtez et en même temps c'était chiant de
devoir parcourir les terres désolé à la
recherche de matériel c'est plus facile
de les voler du coup ça m' arrivait de
voler des choses dans la poche des gens
sans qu'il s'en rendent compte on
trouvait de tout dans la poche des gens
de la drogue de la nourriture des armes
aussi des grosses armes je t'ai vraiment
doué pour voler les gens enfin bref en
sortant de la brise je me sentais plus
fort j'étais devenu tueur de femme quoi
il y a pas de son métier du coup j'étais
allé à megéaton c'est ici que
commencerait mon aventure c'était une
petite ville charmante où tout le monde
avait le cancer j ai rencontré mon
premier compagnon d'aventure Jéricho
mais toi tu m'as l'air d'être une vraie
petite merde mais oui la première chose
que je fis en arrivant fut d'essayer de
tuer les enfants mais papi pourquoi par
réflexe malure
à cause des radiations les enfants ce
monde post-apocalyptique étaient
immortel et ben comme j'aimais pas ce
que je pouvais pas tuer j'ai décidé de
raser la ville avec une bombe atomique
voilà mais pourquoi papi mais pour
l'argent attends ça capsules quand même
avec ça j'ai pu acheter qure viandes de
CAF et un fling regarde il marche pas oh
moi et Jéricho du coup on s'est retrouvé
tout seul dans les terres désolé j'avais
progressé au fil des mois j'étais devenu
maintenant un tueur de femme cannibal et
sanguinaire avec une homme dans
je mangeais les gens mais après je
faisais des petits sourires avec leurs
eau dans l'assiette et puis c'était bon
pour la santé j'avais jamais besoin de
manger pour survivre juste des fois ben
je mangeais quelqu'un et je buvais un
peu d'eau irradié comme ça au moins on
économisait les steam pack c'est quoi
steam pack papi tu sais des fois quand
on avait nulle part où dormir pour
guérir ben il fallait bien qu'on trouve
quelque chose même si rien ne valait un
petit somme dans un endroit reposant et
agréable c'est vrai les steam pack
cétait quand même utile ça te permettait
de guérir de n'importe quoi un bras
arraché un steampack ça repousse bon
c'était plutôt cher à acheter quand même
mais heureusement en fouillant un peu on
trouvait partout plein de trucs pour se
guérir ou est mieux regarde Jericho j'ai
trouvé une seringue dans un tas d'ordure
tuen veux on peut trouver des armes à
Megaton regarde Jericho j'ai trouvé une
vieille poche de sang dans un tat
d'ordure on se fait une
transfusion je bis bien un nu cacola ah
Jericho qu'est-ce qu'il était con ah
c'était ça la vraie vie hein tu es des
pauvres en fouillant des ordures pour
trouver des seringues et de l'alcool et
en prenant de la drogue qui te rend plus
fort ça a l'air génial papi doucement tu
attendras d'avoir 12 ans mon petit mais
papi la drogue ça rend pas plus fort ça
donne juste l'illusion d'être plus fort
alors qu'en fait tout ce que tu fais
c'est
tu parles beaucoup pour une VO toi oui
bon retrouver de la drogue un peu
partout c'est vrai mais au pire il y
avait d'autres moyens pour devenir plus
fort cet ordinateur est impossible à
pirater tiens mets cette blouse
voilà suffit juste que je fasse une
dérivation de la matrice et finalement
papi tu l'as retrouvé ton papa oui il
était
délicieux regardez-moi je suis ton papa
je mange ton
gâteau j'ai des problèmes mais papi
c'est pas une histoire ça c'est un jeu
vidéo quoi c'est CR de qui alors
Monsieur grenier c'est l'heure de vos
piqûes c'est gentil ce qu'il faut
[Musique]
déjà raconte une autre histoire oh bien
sûr mais ça sera pour la prochaine fois